development in the inspirada community
of Henderson coming right along as well
as the potential for a new casino
Madison Kimbrough spoke to local
residents and some business owners to
about how they feel if Station Casinos
were to open a property nearby she joins
us from Henderson with the latest
inspirada in Henderson is growing with
new shops and homes but now there are
talks of a possible Station Casino
opening up here and those in the
community have mixed reactions I think
it's appropriate out here you know
there's a lot of families that are here
and they have um casinos typically have
the bowling alleys and the arcades and
movie theaters so you know lots of
restaurants and whatnot David Heinrich
and his son Ben excited as Station
Casinos is gearing up to buy land in the
inspirada community of Henderson the
more infrastructure that comes around
here obviously the more home values go
up it's the company's newest planned
project as they are currently putting
the finishing touches on Durango station
in the southwest Valley set to open
later this year some residents thrilled
that the value it's adding to the
community While others I think I'm more
leaning towards against Fila could bring
more traffic to an already growing area
I could be persuaded to be in neutral as
long as it stays out of the residential
areas Kenneth Church owner of
world-class martial arts also not keen
on the idea I wish Station Casino the
best it's like any business but
personally I I would not want them here
in the community and while he knows
because he will have something for kids
he feels like it's an unnecessary
addition to their area the things for
the families is awesome but then also
too you have the M Resort that offers
the same things
so why would you need another one and on
Tuesday is when Henderson city council
will make the final decision on whether
they approve the sale of this 3.8 acres
of land 2 Station Casinos reporting here
in Henderson Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now